- FOLKS, I'm Han Scottsen.
And with playoffs approaching, ANXIETY
around the league is at an all time high.
This is NFL DREADZONE.
[Hans:] We begin in Philadelphia,
where everyone is freaking the f--k out.
- To be good or not to be good...
That is the.... uhhh, line?
- UHHHHHH.
- [Philly Fan 1:] It's the same plays every week!
- [Philly Fan 2:] You know who can always handle the bright lights?
Nicky Foles!
[Philly Fans:] Yeah! / For sure!
- Just got a DREAD ALERT from Jacksonville, where the Jags are stuck in neutral.
- Am I the only reason we’re this good?
Or am I the reason we're not good enough?
- [Speaker:] I asked if Pepsi was okay.
- So, um, do you, uh, wanna go all the way?
- Don't be silly.
We have to stop at the NFC Championship
game like always.
- I worry that this might be my last shot
at greatness.
You know, everybody always asks: How 'BOUT Them Cowboys.
But no one ever asks: How are those Cowboys? Ya know?
- Oh, sorry.
I think that's our time.
- OH AND WELCOME TO THE BITCHING HOUR!
Where nerves get preserved, and groans become moans.
Let's start with a quad box in KC.
[Toney/Rice/Valdes-Scantling/Watson:] Man, I can’t catch anything!
- [Mahomes:] JUST REEL IT IN/IT'S RIGHT THERE/COME ON, NAGY/THIS IS TAYLOR SWIFT'S FAULT.
- Seems like a lot of frustration for a man
who, unlike me, can pee whatever he wants.
- Okay, remember this year
you DON’T want to take the early exit.
- I KNOW.
What's this guy's deal?
- It's Ol' Joe, still got a little gas in my tank.
- Let's go to a HEXABOX of all the fan
bases who think they’re cursed in the playoffs.
- [All fans:] THEY LET ME DOWN EVERY YEAR.
- Aw, the other fanbases think they know pain...
- [Crowd:] Awww...
- [Hans:] And it wouldn't be the DreadZone without a stop in Miami.
- Oh god, I thought we had this all locked up.
- Hi. We're back.
- [Tua, McDaniel:] AHHHH!!